Buenas tardes el juez Juan Carlos
checkley está leyendo una larga
resolución y ya lleva horas en esta
audiencia de declaratoria de prisión
preventiva durante la mañana no se
presentó el expresidente Pedro Castillo
ni sus abogados porque señalan que no
existiría un debido respeto al proceso
ni al Estado de defensa Entonces el
estado peruano le ha otorgado un abogado
de oficio para que haga la defensa del
expresidente Castillo la defensa actual
señala que Pedro Castillo no cometió
delitos de rebelión ni tampoco de
Conspiración esto es rebatido por la
fiscalía que señala que Pedro castillo
de acuerdo a testimonios y pruebas
ordenó a un alto general de la policía
para que cierre el parlamento
impide el paso de los legisladores y
captura la fiscal general de Perú esto
se llama conspiración y también rebelión
para la fiscalía existe el peligro de
fuga de Pedro Castillo porque a su vez
el México se ha señalado que se acepta
un pedido de asilo político si es que el
mandatario así lo refiere entonces con
todas estas
situaciones el juez Juan Carlos cheque
está leyendo lo que va a ser la El
veredicto y todo apunta a que le va a
declarar 18 meses de prisión preventiva
a Pedro castillo y lo mismo para su ex
Primer Ministro a nivel Torres por
supuesto estaremos al tanto de lo que
decidan Francisco por otro lado que
dijeron Los Embajadores de México
Colombia Argentina y Bolivia respecto a
Castillo para que sean llamados a
consultas por el gobierno
Bueno por lo pronto el diálogo se ha
hecho virtualmente ellos van a venir a
Lima lo que se ha sabido Es que la
posición peruana es de un total rechazo
a lo al comunicado integral que ha hecho
Argentina Bolivia México y también
Colombia de que supuestamente habría una
situación de
antidemocrático hostigamiento hacia el
presidente el expresidente Pedro
castillo y todo esto iría en una especie
de complot esto ha sido rechazado por el
gobierno de Dina boluarte que califica
de un Se podría decir una intervención
en los asuntos ajenos que solamente le
corresponden a Perú y por eso van a
tratar de hacer una resolución pero sin
que se afecte las relaciones
diplomáticas con estos países hermanos